yeah it's been a goddamn year since we
moved here my god
already this is this has not felt like a
year at all
jesus yeah 2020 has been [ __ ] weird
yeah to be fair
but how is it for you guys your first
year here in japan
spin i mean okay to be fair it's
probably you know pretty abnormal year
for people who moved around this time
you know it's it's been it's
it's been a strange year all around yeah
you know it's i don't think
i don't feel like i've spent a proper
year here in japan
mostly because like i felt like part of
the
experience i was expecting from japan
was to have people visit me you know
what i mean yeah and i had a lot of
friends who
had planned to come visiting us in japan
and it just
honestly that's that's half the fun of
living in this country right it's like
being like oh man
i've always wanted to visit japan or
like i'm coming to visit japan and
you're just like
my boy i got you bro i wanted to be on
the other side of that
yeah on the other side of that fence
because i've been on i've been on the
visiting side and i remember how amazing
[ __ ] was
yeah when i first moved here and
everything was so bright-eyed and you
could take me to a [ __ ] family mart
or a combination
i'd be like yeah yo you eat this like
katsu curry every day
eat this fried chicken yeah
just watching those interactions is like
so [ __ ] fun because
yeah because to you now it's just so
normal but yeah it's just so [ __ ]
daily yeah dude
i remembered like i was at the
supermarket and i would i just thought
to myself man
i remember when i used to think the [ __ ]
was like insane yeah and like now i feel
like there's nowhere else left on earth
where i'm ever gonna go and it's gonna
feel magical
and i felt kind of sad for a second
because that is the final boss
because dude because i've been hyping up
japan my whole like
teenage to adult yeah yeah yeah it was
the one place that i always
really wanted to go cause i went to
america and it was amazing right i loved
it because i always hyped up america to
myself
yeah and then japan was the last place
that i hadn't been to
that was like i really want to go here
cause my parents took me to europe all
the time
and i was kind of sick of you that
sounds so [ __ ] privileged
i was sick and tired of traveling you
know it's no i mean my parents took me
to like france
every single year and i was like dying
that sounds like a [ __ ] luxury dude
we were camping in like tents and i just
liked playing video games and i couldn't
play video games for three weeks so it
was basically being like
forced to be a caveman for three weeks
and like swim i'm like
okay i swim every day i guess but i mean
it was basically the last place i wanted
to go i remember
the first time i landed here even though
i hit hadn't slept for like 20 hours
i was so [ __ ] hyped yeah yeah this is
[ __ ] insane
what i can get a vending machine what
it's vending machines and they work i
thought i thought i would like i
remember when i like
came in for the first time i thought if
i ever move here i'm going to get
vending machine coffee
every [ __ ] day because this [ __ ] is
awesome now i can't [ __ ] stand
vending machine coffee
literally everything that [ __ ] out of
here just give you my starbucks like i
do everywhere else
when you first come here every vending
machine you're like i guess i'm getting
coffee yeah
it's hot coffee baby but yeah
now you haven't you're like this yeah do
you remember when first moving on you
like
nomihoudai which is all you can drink
like was like god
[ __ ] it was like to earth it was like
a god sense like
whenever we'd go here and we'd go to
like the izakayas and we thought we'd be
going to like kinokura every [ __ ] day
yeah like it's like normally not even a
question of course
quinoa cordo's essentially worth the
spoon i think we've said that before but
it's a very cheap very cheap tube
yeah it's like 15 bucks all you can
drink for two hours yeah
something like that yeah but then you
realize oh [ __ ] i actually like my liver
a little bit and i don't want to [ __ ]
ruin it and i also like good food
as well and it's not got bad food but
you just get very average food yeah yeah
you just get better
food elsewhere because i remember like
coming to japan like everything
i i in my eyes all food in japan was
amazing
and then i lived here and now you
realize that it's all
it's all good but there are different
tiers of how good it can be
yeah yeah yeah and i'm gonna i'm gonna
wonder what it's like when i when i
whenever i go back to england or
something where
good food is just so much harder to find
than it is here where it's just readily
available
i'm getting pot noodle the moment i get
back bombay bad boy pop noodles you
should you should just like do the
opposite you should just [ __ ] commit
and just go to a weather spoons and just
be like
i love wet the spoons food well then
there you go let's
see how it is let's see how it is i i i
i [ __ ] with where this means food
what i don't understand is connor's
[ __ ] obsession with the tesco
meal deals tesco meals you had one you
had one
because i forced you to so tesco meal
deals right it's a thing in the uk
for three pounds which is about maybe
just under four dollars four dollars
you get a a nice sandwich a big bag of
crisps and like one of the premium
drinks
you can get like a smoothie you can get
like an energy drink
yeah i took you because you got the big
big sandwich it's quite big and you get
a big bag of crisps you [ __ ] loved it
i remember you were like yo this all
this for three pounds i was like yeah
it's insane right
i i think i'm vaguely wrong and i really
like the sandwiches they make
i remember i had the weather spoons that
i had on in some kind of train station
and i was like yeah that was that was
pretty bad i took it
i took uh joey to the weather spoons in
victoria station it was terrible
yeah i mean i i don't think whether this
means it's terrible i like what's on the
pub though
yeah it does it does but for for the
most part weather spoons is like pretty
pretty decent for the price you get yeah
the one the one there though i was like
we were i think we were struggling to
find a clean
tape oh yeah i was always like longer
than actually deciding what to eat
yeah it was gross yeah because i
remember when joey was coming to visit
me and connor were like discussing oh
what should we jo
what should we show him conor was like
tesco murder tesco murdo
i'm getting him a tesco muted i'm like
connor for [ __ ] sake nobody gives a
[ __ ]
about your three pound tesco meal deal
okay right i don't care
if i become a billionaire you bet i'm
gonna be eating mcdonald's
and [ __ ] tesco meal deals until the
day i [ __ ] die that [ __ ] is value and
i won't hear otherwise and it tastes
amazing okay